the Joe Rogan experience uh one quick
mitch hedberg story so I opened up for
Mitch Hedberg like 22 years ago and he
comes up to me at the show and he goes
hey ID man you're a fat guy I go that's
what he said I go like I could lose a
couple but whatever are you talking
about he goes I wrote a joke that I
can't do cuz I'm not fat but I give it
to you guys because you know when you're
a kid and they tell you to wait a half
an hour after you eat before you go
swimming and I'm like yeah he goes you
should say you've never been swimming
cuz never been more than a half an hour
since you last ate and I go that's a
great joke can I I could have that joke
he goes yeah so then he goes back and
you smoke a lot of weed so he comes back
totally serious goes hey man you're
right that is a good joke I'll make you
a deal if I gain like a hundred pounds
before you do that on TV I get the joke
okay so cut to like a month later I'm
wit nor McDonald's having dinner with
people and norm does that joke about me
he goes hey man it's Artie's never been
swimming it's never more than half an
hour since he last day I'm like where
the [ __ ] did you hear that joke he goes
he goes I heard a fat guy do it at The
Comedy Store I go really so I see Mitch
a two weeks later I go Mitch what the
[ __ ] bro you gave me that joke norm said
he saw a fat guy do it at the college so
he's little [ __ ] up and it goes Hayati
man you know listen I'm sorry you know I
die I get [ __ ] up a lot I forget [ __ ]
I probably gave that to a lot of fat
guys he was the weirdest joke rider ever
because it was all silly non sequiturs
yeah everything was a non sequitur no
bits transferred into other bills joke
joke joke joke joke it's great to watch
Mitch like IIIi get such a kick out of
watching around do a set where he starts
off bombing like in like it I'll tell a
joke and the audience doesn't get it
yeah and it'll go like okay you guys
don't like me it I'll keep trying and
then he gets them and then the first big
laugh he gets he's like a little kid he
goes yeah he was my favorite to listen
to I listen his album on the way to the
airport
oh as LAX traffic's so horrible and it
was so silly
yeah it's silly silly
yeah and smart at the sound smart and
silly my favorite jokes ever is uh
somebody said do you want a frozen
banana I said no but I want a regular
banana later so yes well he did a joke
was he did this joke on TV somewhere and
you could almost tell he pause before he
did it cuz he's getting a lot of trouble
he goes my FedEx dealer is my FedEx man
is a drug dealer and he doesn't know it
all right is to do drugs
I still do drugs but I used to - well
the crazy thing about him is he would do
you know an hour ten minutes of that I
like how the [ __ ] do you remember what
you said and don't say well you're on
heroin not well well that's the thing I
forget you at all italic I said like I
bet on the other team yes with the
bookie I bet on the other team but he
was high when he was doing shows and and
and at the end the last time I saw Mitch
was two weeks before he died at Stern
and then I went to see him at Caroline's
and it was like you're watching this
this genius shell a shell is literally a
shell like like he was he was you know
taking drugs or people in the audience
pills
I took a birth control pill once again I
thought it was a vicodin some woman gave
me I didn't have the baby it worked but
he was like you but scratching at the
walls and [ __ ] I'll give you I'll give
you one more quick norm thing so when 30
or came out got awful reviews and the
reviewer my hometown paper said Artie
Lange has all the charm of a date rapist
that's what it said so norm goes like
this he goes hey man that's [ __ ] great
I go I goes a date rapist has to have
way more charm than a regular rapist
[Laughter]
[Applause]